كانها حارسه المدينه بل اكثر شهده على
عصور عديده ومديده طوالت على اليمن
قلعه القاهره في مدينه تعز تتربى على قمه
جبل صبر الشاهق منذ القرن الثاني عشر
الميلادي تحفه معماريه فريده تاريخي لم
يشفع لها ذلك ثباتت في مرمى نيران ميليشيا
الحوثي تعرضت القلعه
مباشر
[موسيقى]
تعرضت اجزاء كبيره من القلعه بما يقارب
80% منها الى التدمير الاسوار مفككه
اثر التاريخ بادن واثر الحوثيين ايضا فاها
لمدينه تعز المحاصره لا يجدون متنفسسا الا
في هذه القلعه
الوحيد في مدينه تعز ما بش مكان مابش اي
مكان نتنزه فيه غير هذا المكان سابقا كانت
القلعه مزارا وقبله سياحيه لاسيما
الخارجيه الا ان القلعه محرومه من زوارها
فالحوثيون يطبقون الحصار على المدينه
جففت القلعه سياحيا لكنها صامده منذ
ثمانيه قرون واليوم تكتب فصلا يمنيا اخر
من تاريخ البلاد